so let's take a look a little bit at
what the onyx logic portal will show you
as you consider joining this upcoming
program
so once you have registered on this
portal the
logic portal you will see here a number
of different resources that we will
leverage
in this upcoming program and this
includes
different research project examples
processing tools for big data analysis
that you will gain
access to throughout our server portal
which is a server for big data analysis
different coding exercises that will
allow you to take
process data perform data exploration
data visualization and analysis and
looking at different kind of case
studies that
show how these different methods are
applied to different types of
research questions so that we can answer
them in a data-driven way
so first of all there are many different
applications
including oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience and agriculture and
in each one of these categories we will
take examples of
projects where you can understand the
specifics
of the data that is being generated and
the specific questions that are being
asked
the first challenge that we will
overcome is the challenge of big data
and there we will utilize the
user-friendly and logical
user pipeline builder that will allow us
to
do sequence alignment analysis of gene
expression data or even
analysis of the microbiome to structure
that data and prepared for analysis
then we will proceed to look at
different types of
coding languages like python and r
to understand how to load that data
explore and analyze that data in a
meaningful way
so let me give you an example of what
that looks like
if you go right here to the courses tab
you will find here a number of examples
for what i am describing here so you can
see
different types of projects that we will
give you access to
and you will see some examples of the
coursework
that you could take a look at one when
you subscribe to the program
so let's take a look at some of these
examples by looking
at this course called introduction to
data science in
r and i will paste this link
in the chat
okay so here once you have reached this
page you will see some examples of
different lessons that we will go
through including how to
load data and check for different types
of variables
uh how to visualize data using basic and
more advanced
methods how to explore data using
tools like principal component analysis
and
visualization different statistical
relationships
how to perform kind of specific methods
like differential gene expression
clustering k-means and hierarchical
clustering some examples
of unsupervised machine learning how to
perform
classification with random forest and
other types of methods
and all the way to an understanding of
how different statistical tests can help
us extract
meaningful features from our data and
interpret them in a biological way
so you will find these different
examples these are courses that are free
that you can try for free even before
you join the program
and then some of the more advanced
methods that are highlighted here with
a star you can use once you either
get an asynchronous subscription which
is very affordable
or proceeding to look at some of our
programs
so the programs that we offer this is an
example of a program
where you will be guided by mentors that
are experienced
in a particular domain and
specifics of how this data is applied to
different examples
so the benefit of joining a program is
not only gaining
access to the different resources that
you are seeing here on the screen
but also being able to interact with the
mentor and the participants of the full
program
and once you interact with them to be
able to
schedule a a session with that mentor
to have one-on-one uh mentoring with
that person
also being able to interact with other
participants of the program
by joining the slack
channel and so here you will see
a program overview so uh
this is a link to the specific program
that we are starting on june 14th so you
can see right here starting on june 14th
you can see a little overview of this
program right here in the video
here are the different sessions that
mohit will describe in just a few
minutes
and then as you scroll down you see some
of the access
that will be provided as a part of this
program training so you will combine
asynchronous materials
and in-person sessions that are
described there
now many of you are probably wondering
what are the different options and how
to complete your registration
and so for that i want to make sure that
we can
answer all of the questions in the next
maybe 30 or 45 minutes of this webinar
and explain anything that you will need
to know to
gain the most benefit out of this
program but before we do
and before i pass on uh my part of the
session
to uh the next speaker sonalika if you
could uh start the poll um so that we
get we can get to know some of the
participants
in this webinar today
yes sure area uh thank you so much
so i've just started the poll i've got
three questions
for you all and i would want you to
answer these so we can know you
better the first question is what is
your educational background
graduation post graduation phd or post
talk
and my second question is what are your
research interests
and the third one is what is the reason
you are entrusted to attend the
training this poll would be on
for more two minutes and i request you
all to please answer the questions
thank you
okay thank you very much now all of you
that
are already that have already answered
this
question or this poll um i
want to invite many of you that are
interested
in uh learning some of these tools
many of you are interested in many
different aspects of the program
including learning how to code
gaining advanced understanding of
machine learning and deep learning
receive a certificate mentorship
and all of the above so i see that the
majority right now all of the above
okay and so before i answer some of the
questions in the chat which i will do in
just a few minutes
for those of you that have completed the
poll
i want to connect with all of you
in a professional way on uh social media
and so
what i would like to ask is that all of
you
join our group on linkedin
which is a group where you can find a
lot of the
mentors that we have as well as a lot of
the
participants of previous programs so
if you could please join this group
called omixlogic
that will allow you to see some of the
information
that we will have about upcoming
sessions
uh opportunities to join different types
of
research fellowships and internships
that are available over the summer
and also interact with professionals
that will be
mentoring this program and potentially
you could benefit from
getting to know in the course of the
next program so
a great resource that is beyond the
training obviously free
and if i could ask sonalika that you
also post the link to the facebook group
as well
okay so let me now go
through some of the questions that are
in the chat and make sure that i
answer those as well um so i see a lot
of questions here about certification
and different types of courses so
i will leave that for the later part of
today's webinar uh dr mohit mizunder at
the end of the webinar will
explain uh some of those things and how
to join how to register what are the
different sessions
and how to get certification you will
get the certificate and this certificate
will be partly automated through our
system where we track all of the
activity and partly will be
also approved by the mentors that will
be guiding this program
for those that are coming from computer
science background
this is a very interesting question so i
want to just pause right there
so it's very important that many of
these methods and data science
are widely accessible through many
different tutorials and many different
systems online and so
that is perfectly fine if you're already
a data scientist or an engineer
the question becomes how do you apply
these skills effectively
to an area of biomedical discovery
including the applications to
pharmaceutical and biotechnology
companies
or clinical diagnostics and clinical
research
and so the main answer to that question
is that this
whole curriculum is very project driven
so what we will do is we will introduce
you to the different data types but also
experimental design and the questions
that are being asked in the research
papers that we leverage
so that you can actually apply the
methods that you probably already know
but to the different data types and the
different
questions that are being asked maybe in
a domain that you're not so familiar
with
already so vm dev hopefully
this answers your question right there
um subarus is asking if i could explain
normalization in a few sentences
so definitely normalization is a
critical part of preparing your data for
analysis because
many times when you deal with different
laboratories
different types of settings data that is
being generated in the different
settings
is affected by many technical variables
that we don't have any control over
so if you think about distance if i
measure
distance in the u.s in india or in china
it's going to be the exact same distance
but if i measure gene expression
that gene expression is going to be
subject to the technical things that i
have in my lab
the way i collected the biological
sample the timing of my analysis
and so many other technical things and
so to be able to compare
gene expression in the u.s in india and
in china
i would have to normalize them and there
are several factors that you need to
keep in mind
when you perform this normalization at
different stages of the data science
kind of inter process
right so the process of dealing with
that data
okay so about the timing of the
program so the timing of the program
right now is going to
start on june 14th as mentioned right
here
you can see the detailed schedule also
on this link as well and so i will just
once again
post this link right here
um let's see so
what other questions so i am a
bioinformatics postgraduate
and want to start my career as a
bioinformatics analyst or scientist
perfect so shabhita
having a bioinformatics background is a
perfect opportunity
to apply yourself to different types of
industry jobs
and that's one of the reasons why we
also recommend joining the program with
these mentors
who have that academic and industry
background
and i'm sure that they will mention that
in their part of the presentation
what are the skills recruiters are
searching to shortlist candidates for
hiring
again perfect question i recommend also
looking
at the linkedin group that we introduced
today
that's where we post a lot of these
opportunities for
industry internships research
fellowships and also jobs and so there
you will see some of those questions
answered as well for those that are from
a botany background
uh sayida i think that's a perfect
background because you're already versed
in biological data you know what the
data coming from
different types of experiments looks
like
now you need to understand how it
differs
when you talk about biomedical
applications and what are the elements
of
data science that you need to master so
that you can apply yourself effectively
in these new
methods and applications
will this course cover the
interpretation and analysis of
multi-omics data
so for that reason let me briefly show
you
some of the things that we will cover
and these are related to data processing
analysis and integration so what we
specialize in
is the analysis of omix data and
the logic behind that analysis so how do
you actually
take a look at a specific data type and
understand the logic of how it is
prepared
and what are some of the questions that
you can ask about now in the context of
this platform that i'm showing
on my screen which is what we will use
for some of the sessions in the
beginning of the program
you will see here multi-omics
integration and so for multi-homics
integration
we will take a look at several different
methods
that are based on either unsupervised or
supervised integration
so that we can understand relationship
between features
coming from different audits data types
and their relationship so we will cover
that in one of the sessions
it will not be necessarily the exclusive
focus of the program but we will
definitely
look at that as well